let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about conic sections so first of all
what what are they and why are they
called conic sections actually your pot
you probably recognize a few of them
already and I'll write them out they're
the circle circle the ellipse the
parabola parabola and the hyperbola
hyper hyper bola that's a P hyperbola
and you know what these already and I
mean you know when I first learned conic
sections as I go I know what a circle is
I know the parabola is and I even know a
little bit about ellipses and hyperbolas
why on earth are they called conic
sections so it to put things simply
because they're the intersection of a
plane and a cone and I'll draw you down
in a second but just before I do that it
probably makes sense to just draw them
by themselves and I'll switch colors
circle we all know what that is that's
let me pick it actually let me see if I
can pick a thicker line for my circles
so circle looks something like that it's
all the points that are equidistant from
some center and that distance that they
all are that's the radius right so if
this is R and this is the center the
circle is the point all the points that
are exactly R away from this Center and
we learned that I we learned that early
in our education is what a circle is it
makes the world go round
literally ellipse in in layman's terms
it's kind of a squished circle it could
look something like this it could look
like let me do it lips in another color
so the lips could be like that could be
like that it's harder to draw using the
tool I'm drawing but it could also be
tilted and rotated around but this is a
general sense it actually circles are a
special case of an ellipse it's a it's
an ellipse where it's it's not stretched
in one dimension more than the other
it's kind of perfectly symmetric in
every way parabola
you've learned that if you're if you're
taking algebra 2 and MIT you probably
have if you're if you care about conic
sections but a parabola let me draw a
lines here so you know what we're two
separate things
a parabola looks something like this
kind of a u-shape and you know the
classic parabola I won't go into the
equations right now but the classic well
I will because you're probably familiar
with it it's y is equal to x squared and
then you know it could be you could
shift it around and I'm you can even
have a parabola that goes like this that
would be X is equal to Y squared
you could also rotate rotate these
things around but you I think you you
you know the general shape of a parabola
we'll talk more about how do you graph
it or how do you know what the
interesting points on a parabola
actually are and then the last one you
might have seen this before is a
hyperbola it almost looks like two
parabolas but not quite because the the
curves tend to they took they look a
little less Jewish and a little more
open but I'll explain what I mean by
that so hyperbola usually looks
something like this so if these are the
axes these are the axes then if I were
to draw let me draw some asymptotes let
me draw some asymptotes I want to go
right through the right through that's
pretty good these are asymptotes those
aren't the actual hyperbola but a
hyperbola would look something like this
it could either be on it would be like
you know they get they could be like
right here and they get really closely
asymptotes they get closer and closer to
those blue lines like that and happen on
this side too so it kind of the graphs
show up here and then they pop over and
they show up there so that would be this
magenta could be one hyperbola I haven't
done true justice to it or another
hyperbola could be on kind of a kind of
holida a vertical hyperbola and that's
not the exact word but it would look
something like that where it's it's
below the asymptote here it's above the
asymptote there so those are so this
this blue one would be one hyperbola and
then the magenta one would be a
different hyperbola so those are the
different graphs so then you know the
one thing that you I'm sure you're
asking is why are they called conic
sections why are they not called bolas
or or variations of circles or whatever
and in fact what's even the relationship
it's pretty clear that circles and
ellipses are somehow related that an
ellipse is just a squished circle and
maybe it even seems that parabolas and
hyperbolas are somewhat
related this is a P once again they both
have bola in their name and they're both
kind of look like opened use although
hyperbola has two of these going in in
kind of opening in different directions
where they look related but what is the
connection behind all these and that's
that's frankly where the word conic
comes from so let me see if I can draw a
three-dimensional cone so if this is a
cone
let me see so that's the top
let me draw I could use an ellipse for
the top looks like that that's actually
it has no top it would actually keep
going on forever in that direction I'm
just kind of slicing it so you see that
it's a cone this could be the bottom
part of it so let's take different
intersections of a plane with this cone
and see if we can at least generate the
different shapes that we talked about
just now so if we have a plane that goes
directly I guess if you call this the
axis of the of this three dimensional
cone so this is the axis so if we have a
plane that's exactly perpendicular that
axis so let's see if I can draw it in
three dimensions so the plane would look
something like this so we'd have a line
this is the front line that's closer to
you and then they'll have another line
back here it's close enough and then of
course you know these are infinite
planes it goes off in every direction
but I'm just trying so this is if this
plane is directly perpendicular to the
axis of these so this is where the plane
goes behind it
the intersection of this plane and this
cone is going to look like this and
we're looking at it from an angle but if
you were to look at straight down if
you're really sitting here and you look
at this plane if you're looking at right
above if I were to just flip this over
like this so this is we're looking
straight down on this plane that
intersection would be a circle now if we
take the plane and we tilt it down a
little bit if we tilt it down a little
bit so instead of that we have a
situation like this let me see if I can
get do it justice we have a situation
where it's
you know the SOT whoops let me undo that
and it undo where it's like this it has
another side like this and then I
connect them so that's the plane now the
intersection of this plane which is not
which is now not orthogonal or it's not
perpendicular to the axis of this of
this 3-dimensional cone if you take the
intersection of that plane in that cone
in future videos and you don't do this
in your algebra 2 class but eventually
we'll kind of do the three-dimensional
intersection and prove that this is
definitely the case you definitely do
get the equations which I'll show you in
the not too far future this intersection
would look something like this I think
can visualize it right now it would look
something like this
right and if you were to look straight
down on this plane if you look right
above the plane this would look
something this figure I just drew in
purple would look something like this no
I didn't draw it that well would be an
ellipse you know what an ellipse looks
like and if I tilted it the other way
the ellipse would be would kind of it
would squeeze the other way but that
could just use general sense of why it's
why both of these are conic sections now
something very interesting if we keep
tilting this plane so if we tilt the
plane so it's it's so let's say we're
pivoting around that point so when au
the put my plane let me see if I can do
this it's a good exercise in
three-dimensional drawing let's say it
looks something like this I want to go
through that point well so this is my
three-dimensional plane and I'm drawing
it in such a way that it only intersects
this bottom cone and it's the surface of
the plane is parallel to the side of
this top cone in this case the
intersection of the plane and the cone
is going to it's going to intersect
right at that point I'm kind of you can
almost view that I'm pivoting around
this point and the intersection of this
point and the plane and the cone well
this now would look the intersection
would look something like this it would
look like that and would keep going down
so if I were to draw it it would look
like this if I was right above the plane
if I would
just draw the plane and there you get
your parabola so that's interesting if
you keep kind of tilting if you start
with a circle tilt a little bit you get
an ellipse you get an ellipse you get
kind of a more and more skewed ellipse
more and more skewed ellipse and at some
point it looks kind of you know the
ellipse keeps getting more and more
skewed like that it's some kind of kind
of pops right when you write when you
become exactly parallel to the side of
this top cone and I'm doing it all vary
in exact right now but I think I want to
give you the tuition it pops and it
turns into a parabola so you can kind of
view a parabola there is this
relationship it's kind of the parabola
is what happens when one side of an
ellipse pops open and you get this
parabola and then if you keep tilting
this plane if you keep tilting the plane
I'll do it in another color so the
intersects both sides of the cone so let
me see if I could draw on that so if
this is my new plane whoops that's good
enough so if my plane looks like this I
know it's very hard to read now and you
wanted the intersection of this plane
this green plane in the cone I should
probably redraw it all but hopefully
you're not getting overwhelmingly
confused the intersection would look
like this it would intersect the bottom
cone there and intersect the top cone
over there and then you would have
something like this you would have this
would be the intersection of the plane
and the bottom cone and then up here
would be the intersection of the plane
in the top gonna remember this plane
goes off in every direction infinitely
so that's just a general sense of what
the conic sections are and why frankly
they're called conic sections and let me
know if if this got confusing because
maybe I'll do another video I'll redraw
it a little bit cleaner maybe I can find
some kind of neat 3d application that
that can do it better than I can do it
but these are this this kind of just the
reason why they all are conic section
why they really are related to each
other and we'll do that in a little more
depth mathematically in a few videos but
in the next video now that you know what
they are and why they're all called
conic sections I'll actually talk about
the formulas about these and how do you
recognize the formulas and given a
formula how do you actually plot the
graphs of these conic sections see in
the next video